lena dunham is one of the most open and
honest celebrities out there especially
when it comes to her body and what she's
been through she's taking to social
media once again to celebrate the way
herself is changing with a couple of
underwear pics here's a look
so Lena posted these side-by-side photos
they're about a year apart as she says
in her text on the screen they're the
most recent on the right seemingly right
after Thanksgiving of this year and she
notes that in the pic on the left she
was sick and she says quote fetishizing
her body even though she was ill then
she says in the picture on the right
she's happier and healthier now Lena's
jurrasic weight loss over the last year
can be attributed at least in part to
major surgery she underwent a complete
hysterectomy here's a post surgery photo
that she shared on Instagram and this is
not the first time that the 32 year old
actress writer and producer has bared
her soul and other things online
Lena recently posted this sultry pic
she's wearing her savage by Fenty
lingerie
we actually blurred out a nipple here
and she captioned it quote the sweet
holiday irony of them birthing hips on a
girl with no uterus of course talking
about her body and again hysterectomy
that she underwent being open about it
she continued her body positivity on
Instagram with this video of her shaving
her armpits I have to say a little
aggressively I can't I can't shave like
that I got a no Lena's secret here
because she's really going after it and
not not apparently not seemingly using a
shaving cream but we give Lena all the
credit because she's open she's honest
and she shares and bares it all and glad
to see again in that new side-by-side
picture if we can bring that up one more
time that Lena is saying that while she
was fetishizing her body while ill back
in summer 2017 the for Thanksgiving 2018
she is healthier she is happier she puts
up a heart emoji over that newer
sure on the right she says that feeling
when you feel it's so hard that you take
it from stories to feed she wanted to
post that one on her main feed good for
Lena
[Music]
[Applause]